Health care is a diverse and rich field for research and analytics.
We will now consider a few examples to explore that diversity.
The historic gold standard for developing new medical knowledge,
is the controlled clinical trial.
You have two equivalent,
randomly selected patient groups,
alternate therapies are a new therapy and
a placebo and see which group does better over time.
These are difficult to do.
Finding and recruiting the right patients is hard.
These trials take a long time and they're expensive.
However, if the question is whether a new treatment works
better than current treatments in actual human patients,
there's currently not a good alternative approach.
Next, we will consider the problem of early diagnosis of the disease.
Congestive heart failure occurs when
the heart muscle does not pump blood as well as it should.
It affects 5.7 million people in
the United States and there are over 200,000 new cases each year.
A 2013 paper, calculates that
the total direct cost of heart failure is from 60 to $150 billion annually.
According to a review article in Mayo Clinical Proceedings,
quote "No single test can be used to establish the clinical diagnosis of heart failure.
Instead, history and physical examination findings showing
signs and symptoms of congestion and are in Organ hypoperfusion,
are used to make the diagnosis.
Imaging studies documenting systolic or diastolic dysfunction
and Byer markers, are helpful adjuncts.
Thus, the diagnosis of congestive heart failure may require many types of clinical data.
A point you should remember when I interviewed Dr. Jimeng Sun in the next segment.
Providing help for this problem comes from predictive analytics,
his area of research.
Finally, a different question,
what is the optimal treatment strategy among
already known and available options for a given group of patients?
As opposed to the classic research questions determining optimal treatment,
will require many alternative experiments.
That is, trying every possible treatment strategy on groups of similar patients.
These types of questions are best addressed through
modeling and simulation using digital health data.
There are a number of techniques for doing this.
Again, this is not an analytics lesson,
but we will be interviewing researchers who do this kind of
work to get a high level view of it in healthcare.